today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent flows with strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
convalescent
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in moroni virus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment be afraid of it feel
great like
better than i have in a long time be
afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have to put
on a virus don't be afraid of it and now
i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life
be afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
afraid of it as your leader i had to do
that i knew there's danger do it but i
had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
all right welcome everybody what a day a
really incredible day we're down to the
last
um really the last 24 hours of
campaigning donald trump
planning on going late tonight he
actually has let's pull up his schedule
the schedule's already a mess just so
everybody knows but
trump actually has a rally scheduled for
11 pm
eastern tonight i can only imagine that
that will start after midnight i mean
he's he's running
so far behind every single day as usual
i would assume that this'll if if this
11 pm
rally starts before midnight i would be
shocked
uh completely and totally shocked but in
any case we are
right now waiting on joe biden
to deliver remarks at a drive-in event
in philadelphia
scheduled for 17 minutes from now and
waiting on donald trump
in north carolina now trump was supposed
to
leave dubuque iowa almost two hours ago
i think he only left about a half hour
ago
so it's completely unpredictable
where trump is and what the schedule's
going to be
if we wanted to we could always see what
the situation was
on this channel right side broadcasting
um
this is actually not satire but i'll
just let you guys listen to a few
seconds of it this is in
hickory north carolina take a listen
this is actually this is not satire
auburn alabama 36830
and that is also on our website so you
guys can
find that there and please follow us on
social media and share this stream
um there's the lights coming in they're
super bright but i'm sorry it's a little
blinding
anyway so as you can see really a lot of
high level uh important ideas being
churned in hickory north carolina by
right side broadcasting right now
um and then in any case like i said
we've got a joe biden event we have a
donald trump event and we have so many
other things to discuss i even have a
new fresh track for you guys today i
have
memes that i meant to play or to show
yesterday for you
which i didn't get i just forgot about
them uh we're gonna look at polling
we're gonna look at maps i actually
increasingly think that joe biden's path
to victory does not include
florida nor florida i don't i think
both florida and florida are going to go
to trump
but i still see a path for joe biden
regardless so we're going to get to that
in a little bit i want to review my my
thoughts on the jessie lee peterson gay
porn
situation i know that stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii was at a trump rally
last night
and i guess there were some moments that
got a little dicey which i would love to
review if someone can send me some of
the clips like i was sent like an hour
stream
and i was just so busy preparing for you
guys
that i didn't have time to find the
exact moment but
i guess stephen was accosted yesterday
at a prompt rally so we're going to look
at that
and we may open the phone lines we may
open the phone lines we have a very
modest goal of 100 website members
and twitch subs all together we're
wrapping it all tight
in a little bow and we're going to do it
all and that's going to be really great
maybe we'll get some phone lines opened
but where to even start let me um
well you know as people are kind of
filing in with their heads down
depressed about what may happen i'll
just read a few super chats and then
we'll get to other things
joe wants to know if trump can just be
put in a nursing home with a mock-up of
the oval office and tell him he was
re-elected not a bad idea
bustanu says i think results will be
tight hope i'm wrong
if trump holds florida over performs in
the rust belt bad night not very likely
but a real possibility i'll get to that
momentarily
samuel says vote for pedro from colombia
spelled of course like colombia
university rather than the country
jacob says thoughts on trump plan to
prematurely declare victory should
people make plans to be in the streets
for protest
yeah so i do want to spend some time
talking about that
uh where was this so listen as i've been
predicting
for a long time at this point the great
jonathan swann from axios and hbo
fame um has spoken to
sources close to trump that are
admitting trump's plan is to declare a
premature victory
and uh president trump has told i'm
going to comment on this in more detail
tomorrow
president trump has told confidence
he'll declare victory on tuesday night
if it looks like he's ahead
quote ahead according to three sources
that's
even if the electoral college outcome
still hinges on a large number of
uncounted votes
in states like pennsylvania trump has
privately talked through this scenario
in some detail
in the last few weeks describing plans
to walk up to a podium on election night
and declare that he has won
of course he's going to of course he's
going to
for this to happen his allies expect he
would need to either win
or have a commanding lead in ohio
florida north carolina texas iowa
arizona and georgia
i don't know that it's all of these it's
just he has to at least be able to claim
that he's in it
in a few of these that's my sense uh
trump's team is preparing to falsely
claim that mail-in ballots counted after
november 3rd a legitimate count expected
to favor democrats are evidence of
election fraud yeah trump's going to say
any ballot's not in
can't be counted he's going to try to
file lawsuits he's going to try to use
courts all the way up to the supreme
court if necessary
many prognosticators say on election
night trump will likely appear ahead in
pennsylvania
though the state's final outcome could
change substantially as mail-in ballots
are counted over the following days
trump's team is preparing to baselessly
claim that if the process if that
process changes the outcome in
pennsylvania
from the picture on election night then
democrats would have quote
stolen the election trump's advisors
have been laying the groundwork for this
strategy for weeks
but this is the first account of trump
explicitly discussing
his election night intentions so there's
nothing
there's absolutely nothing in that
article that is a surprise to anybody
if you've been following this you know
that that has been the plan
all along and by the way i should
mention
if the worst for trump should happen
and he's way down to joe biden if joe
biden has a huge
lead then trump will just say the
opposite he'll say
whoa whoa whoa we need to count every
vote there's still time
and then he will try some kind of legal
manipulation uh to
to extend the process as much as
possible and then kind of try to figure
it out
so in any case prepare for subterfuge
okay prepare for subterfuge um
okay other super chats coming in and
there are a lot of them
uh jeb says new revelations in the uk
about cambridge analytica and trump last
week
do you think similar ads could
manipulate some people into voting trump
in 2020 of course
of course jane sends a thank you
sadiq says i really enjoy watching your
live coverage of rallies and debates god
bless you brother love from canada thank
you
robert says any thoughts on trump
supporters shooting three people over
some kids
messing with his trump signs in topeka i
haven't heard of it
but what we do know is that there has
already been violence
against uh the biden campaign a
um a group of of uh
trump wait flag trump flag waving trucks
surrounding a biden bus in texas there
was even a sideswipe
incident donald trump then tweeted with
the video
i love texas which is an incitement to
violence
also saying during a rally last night
that surrounding biden vehicles with
trucks
is the new hot thing so encouraging
violence at this point
it's at the worst all of our worst fears
are coming true all of our worst fears
are coming true
um and on that note by the way uh
if you're just joining us we are waiting
for joe biden in about 10 minutes
trump's scheduled for 40 minutes from
now i would guess it'll be more like
an hour and 40 minutes from now based on
how late he's running
i have a new song okay this one is not
from joe woodward joe woodward of course
the um composer of such
david pakman show hits as wait where are
they here
uh joe woodward of course composed david
pakman is a beta male
she goes to the best college don't be
afraid of it and
plasma this is a new submission okay new
composer this is jethro bradley
you know how trump often says
suppression polls
when he says it it does sort of sound
like suppression balls
and a jethro put this song together for
us and it is a good one
another participant player two has
entered the game take a listen to this
they want to go out and they want to
touch they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression falls you can't hold them
i'm
you know they're called suppression
suppression balls they make you
like feel badly so you said your wife
you said your husband darling let's go
out to dinner and then we'll come back
we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real
suppression balls
suppression balls so anyway if if clubs
ever open back up i think that is going
to be the dance song of whatever year
we get past the uh you know the the the
uh
the virus uh i expect to see this
i think all the top djs you know by the
way
i don't know if you guys are familiar
with lars baron roth
big time dj fan of the david pakman show
i think this is the type of thing
lars would be very likely very very
likely
to be spinning at all the clubs um
so anyway that that's going on and
otherwise
we have a bunch of events i'm glad
you're joining me we are going to look
at a lot a lot a lot of different things
here
yeah that one you want that song to be
longer you want it to just go on
for sure okay let me do a few thank yous
guys
we're throwing everything at the wall
today whoa excuse me i just hit
my mic stand i don't know if that was
loud but i apologize
we're throwing everything at the wall
today to see what sticks
i want to say thanks to jonathan sibley
who's new member number one today
stephanie melfi is new member number two
corbin ordell is new member number three
a has pledged on patreon we're literally
counting
everything today that's number four and
thanks to twitch
we also have four new twitch subs which
already gets us to eight and puts us in
a very strong position
uh to get things going okay a few other
super chats here
uh let's see what we've got i hate juice
says let's go joe thanks deepak man for
all you do
physics rigor says david could you
please try and actually do
do some analysis saying could you
imagine over and over is useless
um okay yeah i don't know if you've ever
seen any of the clips i do
uh but physics by all means remember if
you're not pleased with anything i'm
doing
you're under no obligation to watch
tyler and the resident says sir have you
looked very strongly at texas early
voting surpassing 2016 total
can't wait for your election night
coverage thank you yeah uh we have
looked at that
number of clips about it annunziata says
you should watch the van jones ted chat
about how trump could steal the election
by not conceding and a lot more it was
interesting
i love mika tan says hey david here's
five bucks thanks for your interview
with barbara freese
on her book industrial strength denial
the book was excellent
thank you ill scooch says thanks for the
coverage and commentary of these
maelstroms
your dry humor moistens my cold lefty
heart
wow attila says hey david
as some numbers are pretty close do you
think there's more hiding trump voters
or biden voters
any historical data on this i don't
think that the election will come down
to
shy voters i think the election will
come down
to whether people shift last minute
voter intimidation
whether all votes are counted etc but i
guess this is as good an opportunity as
any
to pull up my map again i do
i am sort of like narrowing down on what
my most likely path
to victory would be for each candidate
and i'm increasingly thinking that
florida's going red
and the reason i'm thinking that is some
recent florida polls
seem to be going a little bit better for
trump than they had been and
trump having momentum in florida heading
into the election doesn't make me super
confident
and some democratic strategists on the
ground in florida have said to me
completely off the record and obviously
i won't say who it is
that they believe the existing early
numbers
are not that great actually for joe
biden now of course if you look at the
get
github data on early voting in florida
you see well hold on total voted
democrats 39 republicans 38
what i'm being told and again this is
all speculative but we want to go in as
as cautiously as possible the
independents
which make up 21 of the vote so far
the belief is that the independence may
be sliding a little bit in the direction
of trump
so just for our and a lot of them are
latino voters as people in the twitch
chat are pointing out that's exactly
right
so my thought is we don't count on
florida
so then as we start filling in the map
um
and uh you know start adjudicating some
of these for each candidate
you very quickly start to get a scenario
uh new york of course these are all
going red
this is blue red red red
blue blue blue blue
red red red blue red red
blue red red red red red
um so minnesota i believe is going blue
um south carolina of course read i
believe in the end you you can't count
if if a democrat has a path that depends
on texas i think it's a bad idea okay
so let's just for our sake assume that
texas and florida
and ohio just assume we don't have any
of them okay
it actually doesn't look that bad for
joe biden i think iowa we have to assume
goes red
i do think nevada is going to go blue
let's even assume arizona goes red
and georgia goes red it's actually still
okay for joe biden i think north
carolina is going to go to biden
in fact at this point i see north
carolina as
more likely blue than i see florida
going blue you guys can disagree with me
on that if you want
and then what you have is a situation
where biden needs two out of three
of these remaining states if biden gets
wisconsin and michigan
trump can take pennsylvania if trump
gets michigan
but biden gets pennsylvania he still
wins
and if trump were to get wisconsin and
biden gets michigan
and pennsylvania biden wins i actually
think that
wisconsin's going blue and michigan is
is the only one that might go red
let me pull up uh and i'll tell you why
i say that
wisconsin trump biden wisconsin does not
appear to be close right now
biden plus 6.6 and importantly
there is no momentum for trump that was
one of the things a lot of people forget
in 2016 yes the polls said hillary was
winning michigan in wisconsin
but trump had momentum going into
election day where one would say well if
there had been three more days of polls
they might have been tied in michigan on
the other hand if you look at the latest
polling
trump biden biden is still winning
michigan by almost as much as
as wisconsin but trump is spiking
and this is why i say if trump is to win
wisconsin or michigan i think it's
michigan that that it would be
and then you have pennsylvania and
pennsylvania i'm not even pretending to
know what's going to happen in
pennsylvania
biden has a lead in pennsylvania but
there is such
unpredictability there so that's where
i'm getting to
like if you say david what's a
conservative but realistic
win for joe biden that assumes trump
does better than he's polling
this is it it's all these maybes texas
and georgia and florida
they go to trump trump gets ohio and
trump
even gets michigan but then with
wisconsin and pennsylvania joe biden
wins
so this is like my thought process
going in now of course it could get much
better
it could get much better for biden biden
could get arizona
biden could get florida biden could get
michigan
biden could get ohio biden could get
georgia biden could get texas but
i i if you if you're asking me just even
odds who wins
i i think biden wins and he of course
could lose
if you say now you give me odds do i
think biden gets 400 electoral votes the
way some people are saying
absolutely not because as you can see
all of the paths to 400
require running the table and taking
texas and georgia i don't know any other
way i mean if he doesn't get texas and
georgia
there's people saying what if south
carolina goes blue
and then iowa could go blue i don't see
anything else
i don't see any path to 400 for biden
if he doesn't get texas okay so texas
and these others without georgia
i don't even think we should be thinking
about biden 400.
no way and again yeah as people are
saying whoever said south carolina might
go blue i think there's no way in hell
um you know other maybes would be uh
the new nebraska second district could
be one
that goes to biden there's the idea that
maybe
a district in maine could go to trump i
just really don't think we should be
thinking about those scenarios
i think much more likely uh is something
that ends up looking
uh like this and then hold on what else
trump might even have this and trump
might even have this
trump could even have this uh and
even that right like this would be very
very close this is like trump gets
everything trump gets everything but
biden eeks out
two out of these three states wisconsin
michigan and pennsylvania so anyway
that's probably enough map stuff for
right now
uh we are live and waiting for joe biden
we are live and waiting for donald trump
we've got a whole bunch of different
things going on
and i'm glad that you are uh with me
today uh
phones people asking again about phones
yes i i will look at opening up
phones we do have a goal of 100 website
members and twitch
subs and we are currently at
1169 on twitch puts us at
uh that puts us at 14. okay
um let me i hope you
answer oceanova says my oh my i hope you
answer from minnesota today
i don't know what the hell that means
guys i'm sorry
okay a few other things i do have a few
memes i didn't get to yesterday now some
of you
saw my commentary on expanding the court
somebody made this meme pack the court
okay i already showed that one
all before this is david placman
and of course beta male dds jesse lee
peterson
he is a christian pastor many of you
don't know his formal training is
actually in dentistry
and so this is david plackman david
plachman
and beta jessie lee peterson beta male
dds
and then um okay i guess this is on the
the video game pacman theme
fair enough and so that's that okay we
got those out of the way so that's done
do i have any voicemails available
the only voicemail i have available is
one i did play already the other day
but in case some people didn't hear it
take a little bit of a listen to this
troll call
this is what we're fighting guys this is
what we're fighting take a listen to
this
hold on where is it somewhere here
where is my my voicemail now ah here it
is
hey prickles you're a real scumbag
why don't you go back to the venezuela
you communist [ __ ]
pack the court we're not packing the
court we're
legitimately replacing ruth bader
ginsburger
packing the court is adding more than
nine people you jackass
why don't you take a civics course you
gotta stick that mic right up your ass
you stupid [ __ ] you teach
i'd pull my kids out of school if i knew
you were anywhere near them
you're you're you're more than likely a
a pervert
a child molester to you idiot right
what do they do you look at their you
wonder what
what a little dick looks like you know
because you don't even have one you got
a [ __ ]
you don't even have balls balls
anyway so that's a regular collar that's
a lot of projection
and then oh people are liking the
voicemails let me just check i i
normally screen voicemails before we
play them
but let me see if any of our frequent
trolls are here
if anybody else is going to mention
balls then we're going to have to look
at it
um let's see oh i might have some
oh yeah okay so i've mentioned before
this caller troy york who calls as
different fake names
actually let me just keep an eye on
whether joe biden is live he's not live
yet here's just a guy who calls uh with
fake names constantly
hey david this is woody underwood hey i
i'm just wondering uh what you thought i
haven't heard you mention
uh much of it but what you thought of
barack
obama hussein um campaigning so heavily
in the final weeks of the election
so this same guy then will call back
with a different name
uh actually he called back with woody
underwood a bunch of times but then
he'll call back and then
he'll use his real name yeah we must do
everything in our power to prevent a joe
biden presidency this is truly yours
and i am putting forward on my
algorithms and my computer
everywhere alliga rhythms anyway he does
go into marxist socialists later
shut down lock up uh europeans
and i think you'll see many massive
revolutions against leftist governments
and those who are in cahoots
with attention okay so anyway that's
that
um what else do we have
oh i think this is the san antonio troll
let's listen to that
hey pac-man i got a quick question so i
wanted to know
you have you make the claim that them
they uh you know
democrats your friend the little guy
that's the worker
the heart the you know the american
warfare this guy is known for
oh god people are calling the voicemail
line
this guy is known for calling in and
arguing against things i've never even
discussed like i've never made the
general claim that democrats are for the
little guy
i'm not so naive to think politics is
that simple but let's listen to a little
more
oh gosh so i just was
curious who are the three richest people
in america
and how are they voting this year yeah
that's that's that question for rocks
but it slaps
that stuff yeah bill gates i guess is
voting for biden which means democrats
aren't for the middle class which is not
something i've said anyway it's very
very weird
uh okay let me see if i have any other
trolls that called in
um taking a quick look here
that's probably good for now wow we have
300 voicemails
from the weekend people wonder sometimes
people will leave a voicemail
and then like a day later they call and
they're like david i haven't i haven't
heard my voicemail on the show yet
like well yeah i mean we got you know
we got 300 voicemails and we air four a
week it's a little bit difficult all
right good so we've gotten
that out of the way very much
appreciated let me say
a few other thank yous um oh i guess no
i don't have other thank yous
but there are four more twitch subs
which put us at 19.
very exciting very very exciting and
we're standing by for
trump and we're standing by for joe
biden and a lot of different things
okay what else did i have planned here
oh latest projections from 538
and others so let's see i don't even i
don't even look at this stuff it just
doesn't really matter because we just
everybody has to vote
okay so i guess the 538 says
10 and 100 chance that trump wins 89 and
100 chance of biden
and then i guess a one in 100 chance
that's this little gray scenario of 269
to 269 meh whatever
um they say that
the chance of winning has increased for
biden over time
the electoral vote projection is 347 to
191
and the popular vote projection is 53.3
to 45.5
which is about a 7.8 margin which would
be a historic margin check my math on
that
and then they believe there's only a
three percent chance of trump taking the
popular vote i think that that's about
right i don't think there's any way in
hell
trump takes the popular vote then you
have the princeton election consortium
run by sam
wong um he has it at biden 353
electoral votes wait so how does that
compare to this this was 347 okay very
similar
he has it as senate uh ends up 53 dems
47 republicans
house control democrats plus 5
um and i don't really know what
president emmy two
means moneyball oh i guess so for trump
second main district nevada arizona are
important
okay so that's what we have as of right
now
uh and again what does this mean it
means absolutely nothing
we just must vote everybody must vote
every single person needs to vote that
is it
that is it that's all that needs to
happen okay
other super chats let me get to some of
these rick says if there is a state that
goes into a recount which one do you
think it would be
so when i when i think about that
question
i'm thinking you know nobody's going to
recount idaho
because idaho is not going to make a
difference and it's not likely to be
close
so if you ask me what state is likely to
be a deciding state
and lends itself to hijinks based on
what's going on
i don't think it's florida i think it's
pennsylvania actually or as trump says
pennsylvania i say pennsylvania trump
says pennsylvania
um i i think that if i know people are
saying florida texas et cetera
i if you're saying just pick one i think
it's pennsylvania
um okay marcus thanks for the super chat
maddie says i think that guy needs
plasma could you imagine
alyssa says david i've noticed
businesses and apartments boarding up
windows for election night my sister's a
pharmacist and has to be prepared for
riots
what do you think will happen when if
biden wins or vice versa i think either
way there's a real chance of violence i
hate to say it i really do
but i think no matter who wins there is
a
significant chance that there is
violence um
we will be we will be in the bunker
actually and
um you know we we have this secondary
and tertiary studio
and i i even may be going to the
tertiary studio on election night
um and it is we we have these bunkers
in the united states and similar
countries let me put it that way
so we have a lot of bunker i'm gonna be
bunker boy essentially
we have a lot of very powerful things
going on um if you're wondering what i'm
talking about i've actually addressed
this
before on the show i don't really want
to call more attention to it now but
let's just let's just put it put it that
way alex kepcke says since we spend more
on military than any other country why
do we still have 40 000 homeless
veterans every day
that's a great question that's a great
question to which i don't have an answer
daniel krieger says jesse lee peterson
accidentally came out of the closet
alpha
yeah i have that video um
and we could he didn't accidentally come
out of the closet but there is some
controversy
involving jessie lee and we're going to
talk about it
soon very very soon um
let's see what else we've got greedo
says if trump loses the election where
will his cult focus their energy
maybe on violent protests and that's
what scares me
valerie says this is a dark time thanks
for the humor support intelligence and
guidance
sujon chakraborty says narendra modi and
donald trump are two sides of the same
coin one down one more to go
paul eckel with an extremely
powerful fifty dollar super chat says
love the seventy thousand dollar a year
trump wig photos
yes those are good megan lives in naples
florida
says all i see are trump signs even our
local grocery store has a trump and
melania cardboard
life-size cutout again like
like i said earlier this is why i am
thinking
increasingly of abide in victory that
does not
include florida that is why my friends
i think if biden gets florida it's over
but i'm increasingly thinking of a biden
victory that doesn't include it
that's the unfortunate reality
okay unknown geek says david do you have
any personal favorite
rappers or hip hop projects if not how
about long time favorite musicians oh my
goodness we we could fill
we could fill a reasonably sized
pamphlet with all of my favorite artists
there are a lot
um oh hold on a second guys we're
dropping a banhammer i think
man it's just so sad to see so many
people getting banned i have to say by
the way
uh there are times when i will see
a um like an anti-semitic message or
something calling me the k word or
saying david go back to mexico even
though i'm from argentina or whatever
the moderators get to it so quickly it's
really stunning that some some of these
moderators
um are are very quick
very very quick to drop the ban hammer
when it is warranted
when it is warranted and i like that
okay so personal listen uh i am a big
tupac guy
if you go back even further you know
you've got grand master flash
uh what else am i a fan of there's just
so much different stuff i mean i
i i couldn't even name all of my
favorite
um rappers and different music
but that'll be maybe for another maybe
that'll be for a crossover stream
with anthony fantano i think that's an
idea
that's something we could look at okay
david have you covered trafalgar groups
polls recently
no i don't think they're worth much so
i've not been paying particular
attention to them
matthias says is it positive for biden
that obama's campaigning
absolutely absolutely sarang
says as an indian really wanted to know
your thoughts on abiden presidency in
terms of foreign policy towards india
especially given the threat we face from
china and pakistan at our borders
i i don't know much about what biden's
policy would be towards india
so i really wouldn't be the right person
to uh to comment on that
but i think it's an important question
crowbato
where did that go crowbato says
i'm the only dem in my trump-loving
family in oklahoma thanks for hosting a
place for folks like me to go for
intelligent and honest commentary
glad to have you here very much glad to
have you here okay
let's uh i continue to see people asking
about the phones listen let me be very
transparent with you guys
um we are expecting a dramatic decline
in youtube revenue and ad based revenue
after this election and particularly
after december 31st why
uh ad revenue goes up in the fourth
quarter ad revenue goes up in election
years
the worst times for progressive channels
and shows
is january right after an election year
january in general is no good but
january after an election year so
we primarily fund ourselves
through our not through ammo cans of
emergency food supply [ __ ]
where i would feel disgusting selling it
to you we don't do that okay so i'm not
gonna sell you ammo cans
i'm not gonna sell you seven thousand
doses of mashed potatoes
not gonna do any of that [ __ ] we offer
memberships at jointpakman.com
very simple you get the commercial free
show every day
instead of these little clips you get
the bonus show
every day members only uh members-only
newsletters
occasional members only town halls okay
none of this [ __ ] you see that
you see that oatmeal i'm not selling you
guys oatmeal it's [ __ ]
25-year shelflight food no join
pacman.com
all right coupon code 24 oh no how many
hours
48. 48 hours left on this coupon code
2020 now saves you 66
okay go to joinpakman.com
grab a membership when you sign up this
bar will start to fill
and if and when it fills phones open
i talk to you okay and we do that via
discord davidpakman.com
discord twitch subs will count okay so
we are now
at 11.83 that gets us plus
nine to 28. love the twitch subs
remember
we keep all but two percent of every
dollar
when you sign up at joinpackman.com so
sincerely i do hope folks will
will sign up there um
i know some people are saying i should
sell uh you know colloidal silver
and bonus buckets and all of this stuff
that would be dishonest
that would be completely dishonest i
would never do that all right
let's see what else we've got um
okay do i have any new spanish clips i
don't i don't
the only spanish clip i have is still
the one from my
instagram by the way this was me in
france two days ago
just kidding guys it's a global pandemic
uh this was me in france like a year ago
but anyway
this is the only spanish clip i have
published
so anyway that's cool stuff and this is
for my spanish show i do a spanish show
every sunday 4 p.m eastern
1 p.m pacific on the estee network
and very very exciting check local
listings not currently available online
but maybe available online uh someday
soon
okay very very uh very very clever stuff
happening there
all right let me see what else we have
oh i have fallen
embarrassingly behind on super chats
um mitesh desai
says if biden wins what should he bring
as a gift when visiting trump or does
the gift exchange go the other way
around
you know i don't know about you guys but
um
i think that there is not going to be
the standard
um trump congratulating biden
trump welcoming biden to the white house
i am not expecting
any of that stuff to happen any of that
stuff to happen
okay uh taylor clark says please put
toward a macbook
oh i'm a pc guy i don't do any mac stuff
kevin says bra okay wendy says sorry you
have to put up with such disturbed
haters
sadiq says david these trollers are on
drugs
trinidad marin sepulveda says thanks
david for the coverage honesty is needed
right now saludo
jane says oh my god what an awful
voicemail sorry david
jb says here in england i'll be staying
up all night watching your stream
tuesday thanks for doing what you do
david
yeah i i want to remind people there's a
lot of
of of um what am i going to call it
there's a lot of sort of
posturing now as if it would be unusual
not to have final official results on
tuesday
we never have final official results any
election this is what
what a lot of people are not
understanding when we see
north carolina 15 reporting 20
reporting 30 40 50. at some point when
you get for example 70
reporting and one candidate has a five
point lead
media outlets will say okay based on
this
the candidate who's losing needs seventy
percent of the remaining thirty percent
of votes not going to happen
we're calling it in north carolina those
are not final votes those are not final
official
certifications it takes anywhere from a
few days
to weeks for states to certify the
election results
we always wait for the mail-in ballots
the results are never final on election
night but
we usually have no global pandemic and
so we can be more confident
about knowing how much vote is out there
so
the media needs to restate this we
never have final official results on
election day and
i'll go even further in hawaii
when hawaii pulls coal close
it's already wednesday on the east coast
so unless i misunderstand
the forward motion of time unless you
want to become
some kind of metaphysic make some kind
of metaphysical argument
we never have all the results on
election day that is not new
the difference here is we're expecting
more mail-in ballots that for a variety
of different reasons
will come in after election day such
that
in a state that is close
the results could flip after midnight
but
that is not in practice any different
it's not in principle any different than
what often happens
so i just think it's it's really
important to remember that
because y'all are going to get
bamboozled otherwise okay
okay the sun is setting in hickory north
carolina
we are waiting for joe biden still now
running a half hour late
donald trump scheduled for seven minutes
now probably running
90 minutes late for all we know but we
are keeping an eye on all of these
different events
um okay bean says david did you know
every time republicans have won an
election they took ohio that's shocking
i'm sorry not idaho um that that's
that's crazy to imagine idaho imagine
that
stoma says are you going to drink break
out the champagne on election night
should biden win
i hate champagne so i will not be having
champagne but i may have
um i may have a uh
you know a quality white ale or a
belgian maybe even a little fernette
i am argentinian after all the four net
could come up at any time
uh yeah very good dj double a says how
much of a game changer would it be if
biden won
texas it would be historic yeah i just
i'm just not assuming it
sadik says come to canada david i just
read i'm this is totally serious now
i just read that next year to help with
the economic recovery justin trudeau
wants to bring an additional 400 000
permanent residents to canada
if trump wins i would not rule out
doing the show from montreal or quebec
city for six months
i've never been to quebec city it looks
lovely montreal i've been to probably 20
times
i love it i would not rule it out i
really wouldn't and
i would have to explore the logistics
uh of that but that's what i read
bad news from quebec city last night i
don't know what that means what happened
in quebec city
okay we don't know very good joe says
moore and others describe
shy trumpus but is there not a chance of
any by of shy bidenists a spouse who
isn't comfortable sharing in a family of
trump supporters
it's all possible and i simply don't
think we can make any guesses about it
that's uh that's where i am with it
uh everybody running late today very
weird
okay let me get caught up on thank yous
because i know people are saying david
david i subscribed and you haven't
mentioned me let's do it okay
these are joinedpakman.com subscribers
beautiful people
lisa knight is new member number 29.
ashley teats is new member number 30.
john mannella number 31 sean rankin 32
aiden flowden 33 henry door
is number 34. bjark
kaiser halling is number 35
dan ebeling is 36 julian guerreri
is new member number 37.
uh debbie koch is new member number 38
gretchen seeger is 39 fleming sorensen
is number 40 jacqueline beckman 41
austin knudsen 42 and jacob calvin is
number 43
and then let me now add twitch we got
seven more which puts us at 50.
nice uh beautiful we are we are halfway
there and we may well get some
some phone lines opened at this point
beautiful row of sani cans as you can
see here
absolutely can't think of a place i
would more rather be
than at an outdoor rally with 10 sani
cans
crowded together with right-wing
lunatics
during a global pandemic awaiting for
trump to arrive
soon to get hypothermia extremely
exciting evening as you all can imagine
uh love and music says aren't most of
the models going by party voter
affiliation i know a lot of republicans
are staying republican but voting biden
gives me hope for a blowout
hypothetical certainly would be great we
don't know
super guys has the good news is biden
has many paths to win
absolutely absolutely um
alyssa says thank you for providing me
and my family a stream to watch while
powering through this election much
appreciated
kalian says david do you own a firearm i
don't talk about that
not something i talk about kamitha says
is there any way a candidate can popular
vote a state
but not get the electoral college has
this ever happened
well you could presumably have faithless
electors i guess is the question you're
asking uh
i think that there have been individual
faithless electors i don't believe a
state has ever gone
the other direction altogether i don't
think
i don't think sadiq says david i'm a dj
i will make a mix for you tonight
yes absolutely we need that we need that
hugh says listen to paragon de facto
okay
lucas says do you think violence could
break out in non-battleground states
uh yeah i do think so you know today in
the original hometown of the david
pakman show northampton massachusetts
there was a sort of trump flag waving
event
with people screaming and getting
aggressive which required
mutual aid to come police departments
from other cities and towns
it's um it's it's bad it's bad so i i
and this is massachusetts we're talking
about all right let's see what um
what messages i'm getting from our
beautiful twitch audience
peppa z says i have subscriptions on
twitch and youtube
keep it up david thank you thank you
um other twitch messages
geoventure says david love your show
your perspective and commentary of a lot
of political happenings most of which i
would not have been informed about
has me has me really tuning into the
political atmosphere now more than ever
thank you for your content thank you
thank you
other twitch messages love the
commentary take my prime
sub says starbarf oceanova
says i hope you answer from minnesota
today
from the standpoint of live calls
excellent excellent let's see
still no biden and still no trump
man what is going on what is going on i
don't know
do you think trump will faint at one of
his rallies with the amount of rallies
he's doing in one day
i'm guessing he's getting uh steroids
that's that's my guess
i think he'll be all right mike says
it's a very real prospect that the usa
will have trump as president for the
next
a trump as president for the next 20
years 20 i don't know
but i do worry about the sequelae
if we don't remove trump in two days i
do worry
um by the way i'm just curious
when someone will type in chat something
related to
what was being discussed on stream 10 or
15 minutes ago
is it because people are watching on a
delay is that like somebody who started
10 minutes late and they're watching on
a delay
i'm trying to understand like sometimes
i'll see chats that are like
for example about the quebec thing from
15 10 15 minutes ago
did you did you are you watching on some
kind of a delay or what what is
happening
could it couldn't be a 15 minute lag
could it
that delay mobile users have a delay 15
minutes that doesn't make any sense
all right well i don't know uh
all right d campbell in spanish says
the tucson regina romero strong latin
woman
represent okay the tucson mayor i will
check that out that does seem
interesting
dark chip says could the carrot cake
theoretically stay in the white house
yes yusuf says hey david have you heard
of christine
mayone pronounced mayoni she's a
progressive youtuber from canada and has
talked about the us a lot i have not
i have not but it sounds interesting
raniel
says hey david do you think tucker
carlson has a chance as the republican
nominee for 2024.
i would never overestimate the
intelligence of the republican
electorate
so it would be naive for me to say
tucker has no chance
don jr has a chance tucker carlson has a
chance
uh i i learned from 2016.
if your instinct is to say the
republican electorate could never be
that stupid
you're probably starting off with the
wrong premises okay
uh so no i think that that tucker has a
very real chance
big thank you to miranda grievous
who is new member number 51 today and
cara salazar is new member number 52.
also want to say thanks to the latest
five twitch subscribers
which gets us to 57 today if you're just
joining us we are standing by for donald
trump in hickory north carolina
also standing by for joseph r biden jr
in a battle for the soul of the nation
event
in philly and then trump's scheduled
everybody's late all of these events
should have started already
joe biden is running at least 15 minutes
behind donald trump could be running 90
minutes behind
we have no idea what's going on um
please welcome keisha davis owner of
cakes by denise
okay so things are starting to get going
for biden and then we are also waiting
for donald
trump this is the second to last full
day of campaigning donald trump doing
five events today i believe the latest
one scheduled to be as you can see here
let's refresh to see if they've updated
the schedule
trump's still scheduled to have an 11 pm
rally uh we are now wait let me look at
this here
okay so trump's scheduled right now to
be delivering remarks
in hickory it's going to be very late
trump then going to rome georgia for an
event at 8
20 and then another event in florida at
11.
um it's all a mess i mean there's no way
any of these events happen even remotely
on time
so we'll keep an eye on all of this
stuff
and joe biden expected very soon very
very soon
okay um what other questions do we have
here
maddie ice says a trump concession would
be congruent with a resignation
he cannot risk finishing this his term
without a pardon
plausible could you imagine uh let's
just wait you know i understand the
scenarios uh on the pardon
i do understand it but um
i think at this late stage of the of the
election
let's first deal with the results from
tuesday before we start hypothesizing
about that
brandon says have i seen alan lichtman's
prediction yeah he says trump's going to
lose
um and he's typically accurate
taco memes has been canvassing in
arizona against trump let's win it would
love to win arizona
sabrina says david many viewers might be
shifting
to kyle's coverage with joe rogan on
tuesday consider joining in on joe rogan
virtually
sabrina with peace and love uh you know
there are literally uh tens of millions
of people who will be watching coverage
and um it doesn't work that way like
how would i be hey joe i want to be on
your stream not not to mention by the
way
you know these streams are an important
part of our revenue if i just
if i were even able to bully my way into
joe rogan's stream
we make no money i mean it's not you
know this is like people said
david you know hassan is going to be
streaming on tuesday and he's going to
take all your twitch audience
so that there's more than enough peop we
live in a planet of you know 8 billion
there's 330 million people in this
country uh
it's you know i'm gonna do my thing and
we're gonna be just fine
um and by the way increasingly like my
audience and kyle's audience are two
totally different audiences and so i
just don't think that that is uh
i think we're going to do fine i think
we're going to do fine paul says
appreciate your analysis of the current
situation david
becca says my dad has been involved in
texas politics
for over 30 years and he thinks texas
will turn blue or he's extremely hopeful
what do you think
i am not guessing i am not guessing it
could be
anything anything could happen uh we are
still waiting for
uh joe biden john says if trump loses
and moves to another country what are
the chances he gives away or sells state
secrets
i i think those are wacky scenarios
wacky wacky scenarios
um queen says grateful for your
perspective sorry if you've already
covered this but i'm nervous
if elected how would viol how would
biden stop threats and violent protests
uh it's going to be up to trump to stop
them because if biden gets elected
the violent protests are going to be
during the transition period and trump
will be the president during that time
um syed says feeling nervous i know the
polls show biden is winning
but i can't help but be reminded of 2016
should i ignore the polls
all you can do is vote folk check out my
interview with
um philosophy professor william irvine
for from a few days ago
you can control your vote you can
control whether you get out the vote and
phone bank and whatever
you can't control the polls you
ultimately can't control the outcome
so uh understand that and i think it
will make everybody
a little bit more relaxed
what other messages are coming in here i
want to say
thanks to sarah tyler sarah tyler
is new member number 58 today at
joinpackman.com
and with the addition of another three
twitch
subs that puts us at 61 now let me do
the percentage math
we're looking for a hundred website
members in twitch subs we're at 61.
okay uh six divided by ten
is six four carry the zero four sixty
one
61 over 100 that's 61 we're 61 percent
of the way there
um to our goal of 100
members and twitch subs
no calculator needed my friends i did it
i did it
avmu says you think california goes to
biden
yes yes i think california goes to biden
nemos says come to canada david stay
forever
nathan shocker oops i lost that one
where's nathan
nathan shocker says do you think the
post-election violence is going to be
like the protests we saw in june and
throughout the summer
no i worry it's going to be people with
guns and trump flags i think it's going
to be much worse actually
uh okay let's listen to joe biden
on the rainstorm oh the audio oh my god
the audio all right
thank you all kisha thank you so much
can somebody find me a different stream
that maybe has okay audio
and your aunt have done for this city
over the years this is impossible guys
denise is a philadelphia institution
and uh you know when young people you
have money
you've mentored and all the folks have
come along the way you invest in the
community is inspiring
and folks this is a city where it all
started
the birthplace of american democracy
sounds corny but it's real
let me test this other one i'm just
looking at another stream
i don't know if it's on all of the
streams let me see here
it all started it seems to be in
literally every stream
i never believed to be this much in
jeopardy oh my god
it's our campaign over on
the oval back in 29 may 19
2019. oh my god what is happening we've
been through a lot
since then what i said then is even more
true today
let me try this other one hold on uh i'm
just looking for other
we're yeah i'm not going to be able to
do this guys if if this is the audio let
me listen to the official stream
ah there we go i think we got one
i think we got a live one here my
friends let's take a listen
is accomplish these things in order to
get them done
we have to defeat donald trump
whoa
some enthusiasm tap with me
in that fight so many wonderful friends
who are here tonight including my good
friend so the problem here is the
persistent audio video sync
these have been a disaster from a
technical standpoint but at least we
don't have the feedback
senator from scranton a guy named bobby
casey
he's a great friend and i want to thank
congresswoman scanlon
let's send her back to the house on
tuesday
and to voice chair street the
pennsylvania dems
city council president clark and
look we've had so many of you for the
energy you've poured into this election
and look i want to also recognize one of
the rising stars
in our party who's been breaking his
neck for me
for a long time and all day today
malcolm cunada
kenyatta you've been so honored to have
your support throughout this campaign
and i also want to thank philly freeway
for
being here and performing i know he's
heartbroken
he's heartbroken tonight this is the um
the sign language interpreter that we
like the best right i think this is the
best guy they've got this
this is my favorite it means the world
to me that he chose to be here because
he thinks this election is that
important but i tell you what
you got to find purpose because when you
lose a child
you know voting is the only way we can
make the world better for our children
folks
and doc rivers jill and i grew up 76ers
fan welcome to philly doc
and let's bring it home on the court and
in this campaign
i've been quoting doc rivers a quote he
made
after the shooting of jacob blake on the
campaign trail he asked
he asked us to imagine what it takes for
a black person
to love us america as much as he does
and they do
and how it is the deep love for this
country
that so far for too long has never fully
been recognized
by the rest of the country but i think i
think the act
you know there's two ways i was with
barack yesterday
florida there's two ways people get
inspired
they're inspired by inspiring leaders
who do great things like barack
and they get inspired by really bad
leaders i'm not being facetious
when they see the bad side we need
american leadership that seeks to
de-escalate tensions
to open the lines of communications and
to bring us together
to heal to hope as president that's
precisely what i will try to do
philadelphia two more days
two more days
in two days we can put an end to a
presidency that has divided this nation
in two days we can put an end to a
president that has failed to protect
this nation
and in two days we can put an end to a
presidency
that has fanned the flames of hate all
across this nation
millions of americans have already voted
over 91 million
and millions more are going to vote in
the days ahead
but there are still a lot of
pennsylvanians who haven't voted yet
we need every single one of you to get
out and to vote on tuesday
my message is simple pennsylvania is
critical to this election
last time donald trump won pennsylvania
won by 44 votes
44 000 votes every single one of those
votes matter
the power to change this country not
figuratively is literally
in the hands of philadelphia and
pennsylvania
i don't care how i don't care how hard
donald trump tries
there's nothing nothing that's going to
stop the people of this nation from
voting and voting overwhelmingly
and when america votes a miracle be
heard
and when america's heard i believe the
message is going to be clear
it's time for donald trump to pack his
bags and go home
we're done with the chaos with the
tweets
with the anger the hate the failure the
irresponsibility
we've got a lot of work to do and if i'm
elected you're president
we're going to do it we're going to act
we're going to act to get covenant under
control
on day one of my presidency i'll put an
accidental plan i've been talking about
for months
masking socialist intestines and tracing
a plan for the full and fair and free
distribution
of therapeutics and vaccine when we get
one imagine
imagine where we'd be if this president
just wore a mask instead of mocked it
from the beginning
right i can tell you this
and every major health expert agrees
with me i can tell you this
we wouldn't have 9 million confirmed
cases of covet in this nation
we wouldn't have over 230 000 dead
almost 9 000 here in pennsylvania
wouldn't be seeing those new record
numbers of cases we're seeing every day
now
nearly a hundred thousand cases
nationwide
on friday alone more than two thousand
six hundred of them here in pennsylvania
it was an all-time high wouldn't be
facing another 200 000 deaths
in the next few months as the doctors
predicted we don't change course
folks we make up four percent of the
world's population
but guess what we make up over 20
percent of the deaths
this president knew back in january how
deadly this virus was
you may have heard me say the
intelligence committee
community briefed him on it he said no i
never met i never read the briefing
well that didn't surprise me that he
doesn't read
but but
he was lying he knew how bad it was
he hid it from the american people he
went on record
he went on record with a leading
journalist he said he knew
he knew how dangerous it was but he lied
to the american people
he knew it wasn't going to disappear but
he kept telling us a miracle's coming
it'll be gone by easter it goes on and
on and on
he's repeatedly had the goal to suggest
just the other day that american doctors
people have been on the front lines of
this crisis for nine months
along with nurses and so many others he
suggested these doctors
are falsely inflating the deaths due to
covet
because they want to make money can you
imagine
think about that no i really mean think
about it
the people of this nation have suffered
and sacrificed for nine months
none more so than our doctors and our
front-line health care workers
this president questioning their
character their integrity
their commitment to their fellow
americans it's more than offensive
it's a disgrace he's a disgrace to say
it
especially coming from a president who's
waived
that's the maga crowd of surrender and
the virus
his chief of staff last week said we're
going to do nothing about the virus
it's here our front line health care
workers have given all their best
to this virus everything to beat it
many of them have died but we have a
president who's given up
i'll never give up normal america giving
up we'll never wave the flag of
surrender
we're going to beat this virus we're
going to get under control
but the truth is this is not i pray the
truth is
to beat the virus we first got to beat
donald trump
he's the virus
think about it
this guy trump keeps telling us
what a great job and all the jobs he's
created as president what a great
president he is
well did you know that obama and i
created more
jobs in the last three years of our
administration than the president did in
his first year
three years of his before the pandemic
and how about this did you know
donald trump is going to be the first
president in 90 years
who's going to finish his four years in
office with fewer
jobs under his leadership than when he
started the presidency
first one in 90 years
that's a lot of presidents that it's a
lot of crises
but only trump is going to have fewer
jobs in the end of his presidency
than that when he started you see
i understand something donald trump
doesn't
wall street did not build this country
you did the working people of america
built this country
the middle class building and unions
built the middle class
folks
i believe from the bottom of my heart if
you know anything about me i believe
we we should be rewarding work
not wealth in this country under my plan
this is god's truth if you make less
than four hundred 000 bucks
a year you're not going to pay a penny
more in taxes not one penny i promise
you
but the wealthiest and the biggest
corporations
91 under the fortune 500 who pay zero
tax federal income tax they're going to
start to pay their fair share
because folks
why should a firefighter an educator a
nurse why should they pay a higher tax
rate
than the super wealthy which do you do
by the way
why should you pay more taxes than
donald trump
remember the only
tax return we got he paid 750
in federal income tax how about you
and you know what he said when it was
pointed out last year he said
well that's because i'm smart i know how
to game the system
just we want as a president knows how to
game the system
and lay it all on you ladies and
gentlemen
it's time to end this crisis
it's time that we take that money that
he should be paying
and help you protect your health care
help you put your kid in school
help you pay your taxes look
we will act to protect your health care
trump and our republican friends just
jammed through a supreme court nominee
you know why
they've been trying since the day we
passed the act
they've been trying to destroy the
affordable care act
if they get their way an estimated 1
million pennsylvanians will lose their
health insurance
folks no listen he's going into court
whether he wins or loses he's going into
court
seven days after election day to wipe
out
the affordable care act he's trying
ready
because of his incompetence 10
million people have lost their their
employer-based insurance
because they've gone out of business 10
million
in addition to that he wants to take
away
the other 20 million people who got
covered
by obamacare a hundred million americans
will lose their protections for
pre-existing conditions
including five million of you here in
pennsylvania donald trump thinks health
care is a privilege
i think health care is a right
folks i'm not only restore obamacare
i'll build on it
so we can keep your private insurance if
you choose to
or choose a medicare-like option we'll
increase subsidies to lower your
premiums
deductibles out-of-pocket spending
reduce prescription drug prices by
60 and say joe how you going to do that
by making sure he and the
multi-millionaire start paying
their taxes so you don't have to spend
as much
and by the way this has been confirmed
by all places wall street moody's on
wall street
said biden's plan will create 18.6
million
jobs good paying jobs
we'll increase the gdp by a trillion
dollars more
we're going to make sure we keep
protections for the people with
pre-existing conditions
meanwhile meanwhile some has gone on
notice with all his lies and all the
misrepresentation
he has announced that in fact if he gets
elected
he's going to change the way we fund
social security
the actuaries anybody hear like a typing
noise in the background
full time at the social security
administration says
if donald trump's plan where to be
reelected
gets put in place it will bankrupt
social security
by 2023 is a guy with a lot of heart
didn't he
that's the guy tell that to your parents
and grandparents
look folks you have my word
i'll protect social security medicare
and medicaid and make sure your health
care is covered
but folks
look he's done a lot of really stupid
mean things
but i think there's nothing worse that
he said or done and the way he's spoken
about those of you
who served in uniform
guess what man he talks about you being
losers and suckers
my son beau biden who was attorney
general of the state of delaware gave up
that job
to volunteer to go to iraq for a year
won the bronze star the conspicuous
service medal in iraq
he was not a loser he was not a sucker
he was a patriot
just like your sons your daughters your
parents your grandparents are served
this president portrays himself as a
tough guy
macho man give me a break
but this is a president who won't even
stand up to vladimir putin for putting
bounties
on the head of american soldiers serving
afghanistan
he's too scared to challenge him he's
putin's puppy
that's who he is donald trump's not
strong
this makes me angry donald trump's not
strong he's weak
he commands virtually no respect on the
international stage
think about this when's the last time
you ever heard of a president
showing up to the u.n and being laughed
at by the entire
international community a president who
showed up not quite a day a president
showed up at our nato meeting
where our nato allies the heads of state
of our nato nation
were making fun of him donald
this is president who not only doesn't
understand
sacrifice he doesn't understand courage
the physical courage it takes to serve
in uniform
maybe that's why the six generals
most four stars and admirals who worked
in the administration have since
left and said he's unfit to be the
commander-in-chief
that's never happened before
and that's why the former joint special
operations commander
general stanley mc stanley mcchrystal
former commander of special operations
in the seals
oversaw bin laden's raid admiral bill
mcraven
along with 22 other four stars endorsed
me
saying they support me and they trust me
as their commander-in-chief
look you have my word i will support
our military they're our backbone
they're our sinew they're our life
ladies and gentlemen we have to support
him
and look and we have to vote
we have to vote to meet this climate
crisis
you know donald trump when he hears
climate
he thinks hoax i see it being about
jobs healthcare and safety
the impacts of climate change too often
fall disproportionately
on communities of color we're going to
make sure communities that benefit
by the hundreds of billions of dollars
in federal investment and infrastructure
and climate change
we're going to create local jobs rebuild
our roads fill our sidewalks install
broadband
create spaces to live and work in and
play in safely
he doesn't get it the west is burning
more of our forests have been lost in
the combined territory of connecticut
and rhode island combined
super storms in the midwest wiping out
whole communities
flooding biden's pretty solid today i
must say you know what's happening
we have a circumstance where in the
south
we find ourselves with more hurricanes
more vicious hurricanes when the
president was told that's because the
waters
of the atlantic are opening up or
warming up you know what he said
well maybe we could stop it by dropping
some atomic bombs on them
oh by the way it's the same guy you'll
appreciate this being from philly
the same guy who said the problem we had
in the revolutionary war
is we didn't have enough airports
stable genius
stable genius look
we'll act to deliver on racial justice
as well
protesting is not burning or looting or
violating
and can't be tolerated and it won't
but these protests are a cry for justice
the names of george floyd brianna taylor
jacob blake
walter wallace junior they're not going
to be forgotten soon
not by me not by you not by the american
people
and they'll inspire a new wave of
justice in america
folks we can do this
nothing beyond our capacity
so hulk if you want america to lead
again
hulk if you want to trust americans to
begin to trust each other again
and hulk if you want america to be
united again
folks we can't afford four more years of
donald trump
i believe this country has to come
together when i
announced not far from here my candidacy
i said i was doing it for three reasons
wanting to restore the soul
decency in the white house the soul of
america
i said i was running to be rebuild the
backbone of america
hard-working middle-class folks to bring
everybody along this time
and i said i was running to unite
america
people said joe you used to be able to
do that but it can't be done anymore
well if it can't be done anymore we're
in trouble
i'm running as a proud democrat but i'll
govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who don't
support me as those who do
that's the job of a president it's a
duty to care
to care for everyone no red states no
blue states
the united states so please vote
if you have an absentee ballot get it to
a drop box as soon as you can
or if you can vote on election day
make a plan go to iwillvote.com
pa folks i'll never forget
what john kennedy said my colleagues in
the senate used to kid me because i
remind him of it
why he's going to the moon he said this
is america
and in america we refuse to postpone
opportunities well i refuse to postpone
the incredible opportunities available
in america
there's nothing beyond our capacity
there is no limit to america's future
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america itself
and that's exactly what donald trump has
been trying to do from the beginning
dividing us in america prettiness
americans against one another
based on race religion gender ethnicity
national arts wrong
that's not who we are look everybody
knows who donald trump is
let's show them who we are
we choose hope over fear
we choose unity over division we shoot
science over fiction and yes
we truth choose truth over lies
so folks it's time to stand up
take back our democracy we can do this
we're better than this
we're so much better the united states
of america is who we are
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you thank you thank you an
extremely
fired up joseph r biden jr in
philadelphia pennsylvania
uh wow wow what an event and oh what
folks one birthday uh-oh
every time every time i'd walk out of my
grandpop's house up in scranton
hey joe joey keep the faith
my grandmother is she alive she knows
say joey no
spread it go spread the faith we can do
this
joe biden on fire tonight giving
arguably one of his most passionate and
inspired speeches so far
we next go to hickory
north carolina where i expect a very
different feeling speech from donald
trump
there probably will be less policy and
there probably will be more claims like
joe biden will end electricity and
indoor plumbing
so it will be a little bit different it
will be a little bit different we are
expecting donald trump now
over an hour late in hickory north
carolina
um it's going to be a very very
different situation wow
wow wow um let's see here
i know that i've fallen very much behind
on a lot of different things here
but i have so many people to thank i
want to say thanks to
robert rosen who's new member number 62
roxanne cato is new member number 63
and stuart evely is new member number
64.
that's at joinpakman.com we are also
counting
twitch subs today uh and we were most
recently
okay so that's an additional seven from
the standpoint of twitch
which puts us at 71.
we may do it and as many of you know if
you've been here for a bit
the plan is to really strongly open up
the discord phone lines
if we get to 100 as donald trump is
arriving my thought is
if you've seen one trump rally you've
really seen them all
so let's just get to the hundred we'll
do about
15 minutes of the trump rally and then
i'll hear from you guys
if if you're interested i'm interested
everybody's ready to go
everything is live people seem confused
audio is on
video is on i always i very often wonder
people come through they say david we
can't hear you like we'll unmute your
mute your device david we can't see you
what
here here i am is this live
yeah yeah it's live we're live right now
this is a live stream that's exactly
what we're doing
right now um i'm just trying to keep up
my friends i'm just trying to keep up
okay other um other subscription oh oh i
just missed i just missed like 10
subscriptions on my website okay michael
lederer
is new member number 72. ryan gunter
is number 73 thomas turner 74
laurent massey 75
clayton hart is 76
david burke is 77 and spencer erickson
is new member number 78
at joinedpakman.com unbelievable what a
day what an evening
what an evening it's crazy what is going
on right now
okay let me get back to super chats
because i did miss a bunch of them let's
just look at a few
katya says even if biden wins there's a
lot
there's a lot for americans to change
the trouble with democracy
is that everyone is responsible for the
country they want to live in don't wait
for anyone to save you engage
your country needs you yes
yes well said sadiq says may
allah bless biden and harris david i
think you were jewish and maybe know the
testament
maybe you know the truth through moses
no i don't believe any of that stuff i
am culturally jewish
i am culinarily jewish i am
ethnically jewish uh but i am not
i am not a religious person
um sinsu says of course trump will say
that doctors are inflating kova death
numbers for money
that's exactly what he would do if he
were able yeah this is a good point and
in fact i made this comment last
last week which was uh trump
thinks it's plausible that doctors would
lie about kovid to get money because
he imagines everyone else is as
motivated by personal gain
with a complete and total disregard for
other people
uh but that's not the case not everybody
is as amoral
and immoral as donald trump but that's
of course that's why
uh donald trump's mind goes there right
away
let's people asking about the
temperature yeah people tend to be left
behind
at uh trump rallies especially in the
cold
and then people get hypothermia no risk
of that it is 59 degrees right now in
hickory north carolina
and there are you know guys with cut off
shirts which doesn't tell you much
it could be 20 and there would be guys
with cutoff shirts at a trump rally
but it is not uh it is not a cold
evening there
in north carolina um
okay other super chats coming in wait
i'm going the wrong way
christine says from canada vote biden
best of luck neighbors
nurse asking if biden mentioned a
stimulus package he did not
swagador says please vote your opinion
matters love canada
um nicholas says someone asked john i
iodarola on his stream earlier if you
would do an interview with him is that
something you would do he said he would
i would do it on principle i'd be more
like more likely to have john on during
a live stream
because on my podcast tv show radio show
the audience tends not to care when i
interview other people who do what i do
um which is why i tend not to do it but
i think on a stream that would be an
interesting thing to do
uh i do want to say thanks to joseph
bullins
who is new member number 79 today
and nadia la cayeva is new member number
80
at joinpakman.com we also have an
additional
nine if you can believe it twitch subs
which puts us at
89. remember phones open
at 100 we actually may do it today
uh and of course please by the way folks
please vote with your dollars
and grab a membership at joinpakman.com
it is the number one funding source for
the program
we have this coupon code 2020 now as
many of you know
unfortunately i hate that this is the
reality but unfortunately
many of our progressive brethren uh have
not
diversified revenue streams enough
and what happens is when there's an
adpocalypse
that can happen these have happened on
youtube and
facebook they've never happened on
twitch yet but they've happened on
youtube and facebook
you lose 90 95 even 98 of your revenue
the reason we do the membership thing is
i want to be
insulated from that and that's why it's
so important that people support us
directly so then when youtube drops the
hammer
when facebook drops the hammer we've had
situations on facebook where
for eight for 10 days we make zero i'm
not saying like oh we lose 80 percent
we we make zero on facebook we do all of
our videos upload
we we make zero we have no contact it's
crazy what's going on at facebook
anyway the whole point is you go to join
pacman.com
you sign up i thank you people love it
people go crazy they destroy their
microphones they burn down their houses
and then the phone lines open and uh
people people just love it
people go crazy okay other super chats
coming in
woody says plan on catching any of the
kalinski rogan election night show
no no i'm going to be i'm going to be
doing i'm going to be doing a stream
ill scooch says keep in mind that
everything coming up in the trump speech
is projection this is what he would do
exactly the page number one says i can't
wait for mango mussolini to lose
super guy says can biden win the
election by wednesday
sure yeah it's a completely plausible
scenario
um kevin says incredible how many of the
cult members don't wear the mask it's
literally drinking the kool-aid you
can't make this
up you really can't you really can't
linda says are there any coveted spike
studies happening yes okay
so a study that was just released which
i will be discussing on the show
tomorrow
found that the 18 trump events
were responsible for 30 000 cases
and 700 deaths now that that doesn't
mean it's people going to the events
that are dying
as a result of the rallies some people
who go die
but then it's also people who later get
it in their community
when these trumpists then go back uh
and spread the virus um in their
in their local communities 700 dead
minimum
from trump rallies so far
stunning stunning uh
okay stanford university study that's
exactly right
that's exactly right okay another
helicopter coming in let's look at some
twitch messages that are coming in
hardlined said with a twitch prime sub
biden killed it tonight
why did he bring his a game so late fair
question
terry mama bear says why does the
audience have red hats on
because they this is a maga rally and
they have trump hats on
that's why what else
daniel says hey david 16 months in and
still a big fan keep up the good work
yeah i think daniel 84
is our first ever um 16-month
twitch sub which is incredible
other twitch messages i think i'm caught
up
as far as twitch is concerned
andreas says hitler didn't have twitter
i'm not saying trump will kill millions
of people but how bad do you see this
going at worst
i i do see a very realistic uh chance
that in the interim period after the
election
there is significant violence in the
streets
i've been saying it for months my
opinion has not changed
my opinion has not changed another
helicopter has arrived
trump usually in helicopter number four
brooks
says my brother and sister-in-law are
undecided crazy i know
what do you think is the most convincing
thing to tell them to get to vote to get
them to vote biden
listen if if you're undecided 48 hours
before the election
36 hours before election day starts
i i i am at a loss i think it bodes very
poorly for our country
but i don't know what to tell them at
this point
rob says best case scenario with biden
win and debs taking dems taking the
senate what do you think the country
will look like in two to three years
it depends on i i don't want to use a
crass term
but i'm going to quote that recent
caller that voicemail we listened to
earlier
uh if if joe biden wins and democrats
take the senate
and everybody has some balls testicular
fortitude you understand
i think a lot can get done i think a lot
can get done
if um democrats allow themselves to be
obstructed uh despite having the house
senate and white house
then you know the future of the country
is uh
very much in question i dead pirate
says anyone else remember trump's big
projection from 2016 take a look at the
snake poem he read during the campaign
walorismi says i'm concerned about the
sheer amount of work ahead to grow back
trust in institutions like the fbi
journalism science education
that's if biden wins that's why i say
take it a day at a time
today and tomorrow that's the end of the
campaign
tuesday vote wednesday thursday friday
make sure every vote is counted prevent
violence in the streets
etc um let's take it a step at a time
oh some folks saying i should say gonads
instead of balls
all right i could do that i want to say
thank you to alexander
shirleniak who is new member number 90
andreas feldhaus is new member number
91.
marina strand is new member number 92
syed mumad is new member number 93
and siddiq salah is new member number
94.
folks we are taking phone calls at 100.
you see what's going on here right you
see what's happening
uh extremely extremely exciting stuff
going on
uh there is maskless mark meadows you
can pick them out from a mile away
vile disgusting clown of a man expecting
donald trump
if we get to 100 we will we'll do like
15
20ish minutes of this and then i'll do
some phone calls then i got to make
dinner and prepare for tomorrow and
you know a lot of other different things
but uh we we will we will do some phone
calls if we get to 100 um
yeah guys we we moderators let's we are
gonna have to stop
start dropping some ban hammers the
supplies both on twitch and facebook
i'm sorry twitch and youtube um
that band hammers are gonna have to be
dropped i apologize but a lot of ugly
ugly [ __ ] is happening in the chat
um okay a few other super chats skunk
games where'd that go says trump rally
encircled in a shield of garbage trucks
how apropos
wendy says in what parts of america do
you expect violence to break out in
post-election
i think it'll be primarily cities
regardless of political orientation
here is another helicopter showing up
maybe the one uh on which donald trump
is riding
sadiq says david i just signed up only
six dollars a month love you from canada
no no sadiq
six dollars a month is beautiful six
dollars a month is fantastic i love that
you're you're at six dollars a month
yanet or lynette says can i get a shout
out first time sub user yes lynette
shout out john cesar says nypd expecting
protest riots no matter who wins
upper residential buildings uptown are
boarded
up and hired private security armed with
ars
i understand i understand
maria cruz is new member number 95
kat fiergall is new member number 96
and michael haynes is 97 guys i think we
might do it
i think we might do it who's going to be
100
stunning stunning turn of events
um what else we got
adams has just joined not sure if anyone
mentioned how trump has shut down the
garden state parkway in new jersey and
cuomo bridge in new york
hasn't been mentioned didn't know about
it but that's that's uh disgusting
anna marie says make us proud vote him
out we need you guys back
love from the netherlands
thank you anna marie we need the support
we need the support all right let's see
if that stupid country song is playing
yet
no it's michael jackson huh
all right well pretty stupid stuff
happening at this rally not gonna lie
dr chakaseki radiology department
says david you need to start doing ads
for psychedelic mushroom coffee
to get us through the next four years if
trump wins also
balls was an energy drink oh my god
that is vile uh i have some um
i have some friends who work in
emergency rooms and it is stunning how
many people end up in emergency rooms
due to
energy drink consumption um
chakaseki if that ever reaches you if
there's ever
like would there be any radiology
elements that reach you
when someone is in the er for a uh
an energy drink like would there be
something people would be checking for
where you would get a scan of some kind
i'd be interested in hearing about that
um let's see what else we've got going
on
i guess not much we're really just at
the last moment here
expecting donald trump any moment
absolutely any moment it could be
happening and i think the plan is we're
getting very close to 100 in fact daniel
van hogan
is new member number 98 we have all been
so familiarized with these trump events
that if we get to 100 we're just going
to do
like 10 15 minutes of the trump rally
and then i'll take phone calls from you
guys because
i think at this point i'm more
interested in hearing from you
trump putting on his gloves it's
reportedly 60 degrees there so i i'm
i'm sort of a little bit surprised that
he's putting on gloves 60 is kind of
warm right
um i don't know dan says from a brit or
either candidate talking about a uk us
trade deal over there like at all
no that's not been mentioned that's not
been mentioned
let's see what's happening
the audio is an absolutely abortive
attempt at audio engineering
uh but but you know they're trying it
they're trying it
um
yeah uh we will yep so so hold on a
second we are more p do more people need
to get banned
oh my god it is getting really bad as we
get closer and closer to election we are
just being overrun
by trolling all right let's listen
this is just so stupid
and by the way the the audio signal is
clipping this is not me doing it
by the way does the pilot have to sit
there stupidly looking at trump the full
rally i feel bad if he does
likes that's rough oh trump's mic is
big off wow look at this hello
north carolina we're not going to make
it through with this audio
two days from now we are going to
win this great state just like we did
last time
let's see if we've got a different
stream this is not even live so that's
not it
uh i don't know what this is we don't
want to do that
let's see what the audio no it's it's
all pretty bad guys i'm not gonna lie
with your vote we will continue to cut
your taxes cut
regulations support our great police
protect our second amendment
defend religious liberty and ensure
more products are stamped with that
beautiful phrase
made in the usa
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country
under my leadership our economy grew at
the fastest rate
ever recorded 33.1 percent
just announced we created a record let's
try a different stream
and see if the audio is any better
that's really bad
a recent foreign poll just came out
found that 56
of americans say they are better off
today
than they were four years ago under
obama and sleepy joe
and i want to tell you it's really windy
up here
oh thank goodness you have a president
that doesn't need
teleprompters because these things are
virtually useless
it's funny when he criticizes prompters
while using one
you know we started off today
went to iowa we went i tell you what we
had in iowa we had the coldest
windiest but it was warm because the
people were warm and we're gonna win
iowa very big
we had a couple of cold stops today one
was so-called
we talked about refugees we said if they
come in they're going to say i want to
go back
immediately this is terrible let's go
back to i guess this
feed we will collapse in our country
we'll go into
at least a free fall but probably a
depression they want to raise your taxes
what a disaster they want to take away
your second amendment
they want to do lots of things that i
don't think you can stand for
i don't think you can stand for fracking
doesn't pertain so much to but it does
pertain
in a different way to you than it would
to pennsylvania they're taking away you
fracking but what they're really doing
is
your energy costs are going to go
through the roof that will be very bad
for this
incredible state you want to massively
increase regulations send you jobs
overseas
destroy the suburbs well we're keeping
the suburbs i got rid of the regulation
that would have destroyed the suburbs
they will bring it back worse than ever
before
terminate religious liberty eliminate
school choice outlaw private health care
and shred your second amendment take
away your guns
and indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lies
biden has vowed to abolish u.s
oil u.s fracking natural gas
industry look at what he's talking about
doing but it's not him
he's shot okay it's done it's the
radical left
it's the radical level energy prices
will explode
and crippling that will [ __ ] our
country you know we right now
energy independent what we have going
we've never had before
biden's energy ban will send every state
from north carolina to michigan to
pennsylvania
into a very very severe problem
and we're not going to have it we worked
too hard we had the greatest
economy in the history of our country
and then the plague came in from china
it came in from china they should have
never allowed it they stopped it from
going into china
but it came to us and europe and the
rest of the world
and we're never going to ever forget we
will never forget
but now we're building our economy back
up and it's going in a v
but it's really a super v as long as i'm
president
we will remain the number one producer
of oil this is really done
on the planet earth and we will remain
energy independent our opponent's agenda
is a war on workers
a war on faith and a war on our great
police
biden says he's running as a proud
democrat
i'm running as a proud american
thank you thank you very much
by the way i just have to say this so
we had something incredible happen four
years ago
this is more important and there's more
energy
the crowds are bigger everything's
hotter
and it's really but this is for
everybody telling me the audio is fine
are you guys not hearing like the
repetition like there's like a
it's like a fraction of a second delayed
and it sounds echoey am i the only one
hearing that
in the history of our country get out
and vote
sleepy joe biden is a die-hard globalist
who spent 47
years outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in ridiculous endless wars and they're
all coming back they're all coming back
north carolina lost nearly half of its
manufacturing jobs
thanks to nafta one of the worst trade
deals
ever and we got rid of it nobody thought
that was possible
promises made promises
biden and his group shipped your jobs
and your factories to china and other
places
and far away lands raking in millions of
dollars for himself
it turns out we didn't know about this
didn't we
his son was like a human vacuum cleaner
he went in and
where are you going today dad i think
i'll go to ukraine okay let me pick up a
couple of bucks 183
000 a month and three three million
dollars
up front where you going today dad i'm
gonna go to russia
good so the mayor of moscow's wife gave
me three and a half million dollars
right
i'm gonna check my own twitch stream
here's the scary part
the fake news media and there's a lot of
it right back there the fake news
they don't want to talk about it they
don't want to talk about it
and big tech oh it is better choose to
put it on and then they'll
they'll terminate the new york post new
york post i have to give them a lot of
credit
number one they endorsed me which is
nice
you know i got endorsed today by the
pittsburgh gazette and it hasn't
happened
where they they endorsed the republican
today can you
nobody could believe it they haven't
done it in decades
and thank you very much pittsburgh
gazette will well taken
well we got endorsed by a lot of great
people
we got endorsed by great people and a
lot of newspapers are endorsing
us because they know that joe biden is
not up to this job
all you have to do is watch him for
about five minutes
he is not up to this job one thing i can
tell you president xi
putin kim jong-un let me just test
whether it's happening on just random
like if i put if i play a random thing
let me see
i don't know anyway we're we're fine
we'll we'll stick here
whose son asks for 10 million dollars a
year
for introductory purposes right
10 million a year and he's supposed to
be negotiating with china
china would just hope china would just
hope that i don't win because
hey we've taken in tens of billions of
dollars a year first time
ever with china we never took in 10
cents
saved our steel mill saved our steel and
aluminum
industries in 2016
north carolina voted to fire this
corrupt
political establishment and you elected
a president who is finally putting
america first
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because thankfully i'm not a
politician
and if i don't always play by the rules
of washington
and the washington establishment it's
because
i fight for you and there's never been
anybody that's fought harder for you
i had a very nice life before doing this
i had a very nice
what a guy he didn't have to be here
guys he's doing it for you
for us that's such a great honor when i
hear that
it's never been said at any point did
anybody ever hear that ronald reagan we
liked others we're like
nobody's ever nobody's ever heard it and
i appreciate it very much
my opponent is promising a long
dark winter did anybody see the debate
i'm sure nobody watched it right
he didn't do too well no he's looking
remember he said you're gonna have a
long dark winter it's so inspiring how
about somebody says gee
we really like i don't think anybody
likes mine
harry let's watch biden tonight on
television
and he says we want to we're going to
have a low dark winter
how inspiring that is right so he said
that and i'm saying that we're going to
deliver
the greatest american comeback in
history that's what we're doing
can you imagine that way ahead of
schedule
oh yeah we're doing so well it's a
choice between a biden depression
and a boom like you've never seen before
it's a choice between
a biden lockdown he wants to lock it
down let's lock it down
let's lock it down and by the way tell
your governor
to open up north carolina
not that again it's time
it's time it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous
they'll probably announce it on november
4th we're going to open up now
you know they thought our numbers
wouldn't be so good they thought by
keeping these states like pennsylvania
north carolina michigan
how about her her husband roams free
he's the only one in the whole state
no but they thought that by keeping him
down the numbers would and yet
we had at 33.1 that's the highest in the
history of our
country by double getting some tabs
closed out here guys 52
and that was half of what we did so what
you're looking for and we're going to
have very shortly within a
couple of weeks we're going to have safe
vaccine that will end and then look
we're around remember trump promised a
vaccine in october now he says a couple
more weeks
we're rounding the corner but on top of
that we have vaccines coming from
pfizer johnson and johnson modern are
great companies and they're right there
they're right there and we're going to
have them launched and our military is
going to do it logistically
incredible and we're going to start with
our seniors
especially our seniors where they have
some problems with heart
with diabetes problems with heart a
great thing
it's going to speed up the process we
launched and by the way
it does work here i am right here i am
now i like to say that the medicine i
took
regeneron i'd like to say that it had no
impact on me
because i'm a perfect physical specimen
and i'm very young
but i decided to take it anyway right
now it's amazing the things we've been
able to do in the last six months
not only that if you look at all of the
the
what we produce now we've become a
production
incredible what we're doing and what
we're sending to the world
the ventilator is what we're sending all
right guys it's literally the same
speech as always so i want to hear from
some of you guys i'm going to open up
the phone lines at davidpakman.com
discord momentarily so the instructions
are and we'll go back to a few minutes
of this while we wait
you go to davidpakman.com discord
get yourself in the waiting lobby
make sure that you have do not disturb
turned on
so we don't hear that wacky discord
beeping
and then change your nickname on our
server to
location colon name all right
location colon name so i know who you
are and where you're calling in from all
right and then we will
be able to get this is the same speech
as always so we'll listen a little bit
more then we'll hear from some of you
we could call it the china plague the
china virus but he didn't say he said
covet
i said gee that's too bad i said he'll
be fine
about 14 minutes later he came back
i said how's baron doing oh he shook it
off it's fine he's fine
they're young to have strong immune
systems get him back to school
please we've learned about this horrible
plague
that was sent to us by china our excess
mortality rate in america
is 40 lower than europe you know you
keep hearing europe is doing so well
they're not doing so well
and we want them to do well by the way
right we help them we help them
we want them to do well and uh but
they're having a very hard time
joe biden is promising to delay the
vaccine and turn america
into a prison state while letting
rioters run free you know they close
your churches they close your schools
but if you want to riot and burn down
the stores and
have the anarchists out there do lots of
it that's okay
you can't stop that but you can't go to
school and you can't go to church
it's crazy all democrat run by the way
all democrat run you look at portland
democrat
super liberal democrat we could fix that
situation we have to be invited in
we fix seattle because we said that's
enough we're going in we don't care
we're going in
so we were going in the next morning
that night they found out about it they
said we're leaving now thank you very
much
what on earth is he talking about we did
a great job in
minnesota minneapolis all right guys as
we keep an eye on this i want to hear
from some of you guys we are going to
take calls in discord
davidpakman.com discord if you want to
talk to me
get yourselves in the waiting lobby uh
make sure everything is properly
configured
and uh otherwise i will be unable to
hear you
let's first go to andres
from ecuador andres from ecuador
hello
hola
and he's gone all right very good uh an
auspicious start
let's go next to brian from brooklyn
brian from brooklyn you are on
brian from brooklyn please on you you
are on
brian from brooklyn last opportunity you
are on right now remember you've got to
listen through discord
rather than through the stream
and brian is gone let's go to uh
trevor from dallas fort worth trevor
from dallas fort worth you are on
dear god
trevor from dallas fort worth you are on
testing testing dear god
for people saying i'm clearly muted um
i i'm not i'm not muted
and uh everything everything seems to be
working fine and the first guy heard me
then he just disconnected
let's go next to lev
from new york lev from new york you are
on please unmute yourself
hi david can you hear me yes i can how
are you
i'm good um i've just been like
extremely worried i'm only a 14 years
old
right i've just been really worried
about donald trump winning and
how that could affect me at the world
when i'm an adult and i'm just
really wondering what are like the major
long-term
effects of him getting a second term
well i
fear that the long-term effects will be
not just what can he do
in the next four years but they will
also be
does it continue to debase the country
in such a way that our politics are
disastrous for decades to come you know
four years you could say
it was an aberration we sort of have
some ideas why it happened
there's a lot of stupid people here a
lot of people fell for really bad ideas
and there was a combination of you know
a lot of different things
but um if it's if it's eight years i
think
climate inaction is going to be
irreversible
i think the laughing stock that we will
be will instead of
like i think joe biden can basically fix
us being a laughingstock in six months
if trump gets a second four years i
think you're talking about years in
order to repair that
okay yeah thank you very much i've had a
lot of fears and
sometimes my mind tends to wander and
you kind of are the one that keeps me
sane so thank you very much
hold on did you say you've had a lot of
beers or fears
fears beers okay because you're 14 you
wouldn't be drinking beers
yeah no way no no no very good all right
excellent
uh great to hear from you and and i'm so
glad that you're you're involved it
bodes well for the future of america
thank you very much all right there's
lev
from new york let's go to
mingrui from madison i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that correctly
mingui mingri hello hello
is that me you tell me is that your name
uh yeah yeah uh
so yeah so i'm chinese all right now i'm
here studying in madison and
i'm a big fan of your show thank you
i just have a question i i think i saw a
uh like from 538 that the polls shows
that compared to 2016
that like um like the uh
the biden has increased drastically
on elderly voters stuff like that but
his lead within like college educated
population
like young people uh in white black and
latino has been
like cut like for about uh
10 stuff like that so i i don't know
those specific numbers but the important
thing you're bringing up is
typically the republican does really
well with older folks
and by the way if the stream is playing
in the background please mute it because
i'm hearing something odd there my
friend
um the lead biden is doing better with
older folks than democrats tend to do
biden is doing not quite as well with
younger folks as democrats tend to do
yeah yeah
yeah okay all right they said all right
fair good
yeah yeah my question is that like
compared to 2016
there are like marginally more young
people that are
supporting trump so i'm curious because
like
i i don't know like why like there are
more young people
like supporting trump because like
compared to 2016 like there's like
literally no
populist message and like um the
the whole situation is like worse like
i just don't quite understand like i one
thought
of mine is maybe like the when the
economy is worse that young people are
more desperate that they might be
more susceptible to right-wing
like those nonsense that's a very
interesting
inference that you're drawing i really
don't know the answer to that question
it is it is strange to me
that younger voters are supporting trump
at higher levels than they would
typically support
the republican your idea is an
interesting one and it makes a lot of
intuitive sense
um yeah and yeah and i i just
feel like like um like because those
young people will be voting like
for several terms afterwards so
i mean this will have a long-term effect
on for
future like elections or stuff and i'm
just
worried about it well you're right to be
worried now are you
are you working what what kind of a
degree are you working on
oh i'm i'm working and a phd
student okay and what field
oh in material science and do you expect
to stay in the us once you are a doctor
uh i'm i don't know yet i i just
i'm quite confused i'm like second year
and i
i just don't know there are so much
uncertainty yeah right now in the u.s
and
it just i i i'm really not sure
like there are some aspects here that i
really admire but
there are just so many things to
consider and yeah
it's just is it fair to say that your
decision to stay or or maybe go back to
china or go somewhere else
would at least somewhat be impacted by
the political situation at the time
yeah yeah definitely yeah it's just yeah
it's just a strange time like
i think maybe 10 years ago it will it
would not be
a very important factor but right now it
just definitely
will be all right my friend well thank
you i hope we all get
good results on tuesday thank you my
call i really appreciate it my pleasure
there's mingrui from madison wisconsin
presumably love it
okay let's go and check in with a couple
of other people why don't we let's go to
um uh where are we going there's just so
many people let's go to boris from the
netherlands boris from the netherlands
euron
hi great to be here thanks for having me
my pleasure am i audible you're you're
perfect
okay nice well what i've been wondering
uh
that the chances might not be that high
but are certainly
there if texas turns blue right
might the republicans finally agree with
abolishing the electoral college
because they would they then lose all
the advantage
and reason uh in keeping it no i
i still if if democrat if joe biden were
to win
texas republicans aren't going to say
let's get rid of the electoral college
because they're going to lose the if if
biden wins texas
they're going to get crushed on the
popular vote so i think they're more
likely to figure out ways to just cheat
their way back into winning texas
is is most likely might there be
any other way uh in in biden winning
that
could help uh the electoral college to
be resolved
i mean i i still think even with a biden
win the most likely path to getting rid
of the electoral college is something
called the national popular vote
interstate compact which doesn't really
depend on biden winning
so i i'm hoping that biden winning will
maybe create some momentum
to finalize get enough participants in
the npvic which is something you can
look up if i i won't explain it now but
it's a it's a project
um i don't think i don't think biden's
gonna do it i don't think biden
will be able to lobby for a
constitutional amendment to change
uh get rid of the electoral college oh
yeah well at least
thank you for having me my pleasure
great to hear from you very informed
folks
from the netherlands let's go to sage
from orlando sage from orlando you are
on
oh my gosh i didn't realize i was gonna
get put on can you hear me
i can hear you find sage i just wanted
to know a really quick question
um if trump does get elected which i
really hope not for another four years
right how do you think that's going to
bode for trans people
uh not well not well i mean good to hear
listen i i think hopefully he'll just
forget about it you know and then he'll
just do something else and he won't he
won't dramatically
hurt trans folks it's just with trump
it's sort of like
what shiny object does somebody put in
front of him and get him obsessed with
so i'm sure trump would love to uh
do some things to further attack trans
people but it's quite possible he'll
just be busy with other things and
it'll just really be a sort of luck of
the draw thing sadly
okay yeah well thank you i appreciate it
my pleasure sage from orlando there we
go
let's next go to susie from minnesota
susie from minnesota you're on the air
susie from minnesota we had such a
beautiful streak of perfect phone calls
uh would love for you to unmute so i can
hear you
and last chance for susie from minnesota
susie i'm told that you are deafened you
need to
undefend your entire system there all of
your elements must be undeafened
all right and that's too bad was looking
forward to speaking to susie from
minnesota
let's go next to
um we've got a bunch of people from
let me go to cody from virginia
cody from virginia you were on
hi david can you hear me yes i can
um so i was just call calling to ask you
a
question about a talking point that i
heard from the right today
um i was listening to the candace owens
and uh someone else's debate
it's funny already yeah go on was tommy
larry
and brian conan i think his name is or
something like that okay
um she asked him what has biden done
uh for the last 40 years of uh being in
office or whatever
and he couldn't really give an answer do
you have an answer for that
this is very it's a very stupid question
because it's like
what what did trump do before he was
president the question is what are their
platforms as
presidential candidates it's like biden
while he was part of the obama
administration
got the stimulus done he helped get
obamacare done biden as a senator
much like every senator sponsored and
helped get through
all sorts of different bills stimulus
packages
uh uh financial regulation
you know it's what is do they want a
list of things
if you give them a list of things
biden's name was on then they'll say
well but that what biden didn't do that
alone
it's like well right that's how being in
the senate works it's a hundred votes
votes it's one of the stupidest
discussions the question is
what does trump propose to do in his
second term he still hasn't even
answered the question
other than saying he'll do the things he
promised to do in his first term
versus what does joe biden have on his
platform for president that that's what
matters
yeah yeah i mean i agree i just i i like
to know how
like when these things come up in my
life yeah with the best ways to respond
to them you know
listen it's 36 hours before the election
if that comes up in your life now
the way i would respond is saying are
you really so stupid
that that's what you're saying do you
even understand what's implicit by
asking me that question
does a list of joe biden's votes from
1992 determine whether you'll vote for
trump tomorrow
are you are you genuinely that stupid
that's how i would react at this point
there's no time for this nonsense
yeah yeah usually it comes up in my
family though so i can't be like that
but uh no okay fair yeah
all right well i thank you for taking my
call my pleasure thank you
thank you for calling in i appreciate
that all right let's get
to a couple of other people we don't
have unlimited
opportunities but i do want to hear from
some folks
let's go to fed from
spain fed from spain
if it's okay for him to ask in spanish
portfolio
um
so the question is given that the
president of the united states
so significantly influences policy
within and and with europe how would a
trump reelection influence that
so is it
so i'll answer in english um essentially
uh donald trump being re-elected
would keep the united states less as an
ally to europe than than an adversary
which unfortunately is what the united
states has become and unfortunately
because
so many of the economic powerhouses are
in europe and asia but in europe we're
going to be
on the outside again for another four
years on climate we're going to be
going at it alone when it comes to trade
and doing ridiculous things like the
chinese trade
policy the trade war the tariffs etc so
trump for another four years doesn't
bode well for relations
with uh with asia and it doesn't bode
well for relations with europe
unfortunately so my expectation would be
to see europe
say if trump gets four more years we
just have to do our own thing we can't
count
on the united states anymore if trump
gets reelected
yes disquieting
okay very very nice there it is a
beautiful phone call
from spain a perfect phone call i would
even say
let's go next to matt from
hickory north carolina in the
same place as trump is speaking right
now what's going on there
hi can you hear me yes i can hi
thanks for taking my call um there's
something almost
traumatic about seeing the mountains and
the skyline i grew up with in the
background of that trump street
yeah you know my my step-grandmother is
there tonight and
she's elderly and i'm honestly concerned
about her health living in that crowd
um i know she's not wearing a mask um
i i guess i have less of a question more
of a comment i'm i'm working on a degree
from home this summer
yeah and i spend a lot of time working
from home and the only time i really get
to get out is when i go for a drive out
in the country
and it's country i grew up in it's very
rural um the number of trump flags and
signs
is just alarming every fifth vehicle on
the road is a pickup with one or two or
three trump flags flying on the bed
you may have gotten the point earlier
about you think the potential for
political violence is in the cities but
i'm just
really honestly worried about what will
happen to the rural folks
i it's not that i don't think things
will be happening in rural areas and i
love that you're saying it that way and
not
rural as we've heard some people say it
recently
um and i think there will be things
happening in the rural areas but due to
the lower population density they
will there will simply be fewer of them
in terms of the number of people
affected that's my sense
right but i don't think you will be
unscathed let me put it that way
yeah i mean our family's honestly scared
to put a biden sign in our yard
if i lived in some of these parts uh i i
would also
want to just be seen as non-political i
would not want to be public about my
political orientation to be perfectly
frank
right well thank you for taking my call
i appreciate it my pleasure great to
hear from you and uh
the best for grandma we i would be
worried
let's go to one of our um oh hold on a
second let me let me bring on
i want to go to jaby gatz
but it looks like jaby gatz is already
on jaby are you
what how are you i didn't even bring you
on is it because you're a moderator that
you're just here i'm trying
do i not have control over your audio
that can't be
yeah i don't know i'm just moderating um
um so you can go ahead and just pull
someone else on oh my god okay well
listen i really appreciate your work and
all of the moderators you're doing a
hell of a job
thank you all right jabby gatz there we
go uh
an errant phone call there with jaby
gatz
let's go to tom from latits pennsylvania
you're on dude you can hear me
yes i can hey what's going on
i man i was just hearing about the
disconnect in the polls in pennsylvania
i don't know if you've seen this
yeah the philly suburbs have like uh
montgomery
bucks county have um some weird
situ like differences in polling on the
level and the the local races compared
to the state level polling
yeah um trump did really well in the
philly suburbs
um which is one of the reasons he won
now
those polls this year um
are way out of line with the state
polling which shows him
relatively close and the local polls
kind of show him
not even having a chance in that area i
was just wondering
what you made it make of that if there's
any
that could so here's my thought or i
have seen this
if you look at state polls pennsylvania
looks much closer than if you look at
some of these
local polls do you know what this means
uh it means to vote that's exactly right
i didn't even need to
you you could have taken this phone call
and fielded it that is absolutely all it
means
i don't know what to make of it we are
36 hours out
and all it means is we must vote because
we don't know what the hell is going on
uh yeah um i mean uh
as you can tell from lititz pennsylvania
we had we had a black lives matter rally
here actually in uh july
i was led by a 17 year old girl just
graduated high school
yeah so we're not all uh crazy red hats
i believe it i believe it no i know that
for sure and i know it's
lititz right is that the right
pronunciation yeah yeah that's right
yeah but it just
there's nothing better than pronouncing
it latits uh okay
listen i hope that you guys are on the
right side of history on tuesday
absolutely i already voted thank you
very much excellent all right there we
go
um let's see who else we can talk to
um why don't we go there's just so we've
had a lot of uh
a lot of uh parts of the country covered
so far but i'm trying to see where else
i want to go
here um why don't we go
to is this
is this alicia from san francisco i
can't see the full name for whatever
reason it is yes
alicia how are you i'm doing well
yourself
good it sounds crazy where you are uh my
three-year-old i'm sorry oh no that's
fine
we're in san francisco it's a little
crunched here yes
um i was thank you for taking my call i
was pleasure calling
to um tell you that we have uh
two first-time voters here we're i'm 33
he's 38.
we voted for biden uh we weren't really
into politics before but he's kind of a
middle leaning right and i'm
more left uh so we have a lot of good
discussions with each other
um but we both ended up voting for biden
which was great and i also got a friend
of mine the other day in texas who's not
into politics
uh got her to vote for biden as well so
i'm really happy about that
right yes but i just wanted to see if i
could
um i know you have a lot more people
that listen to you than me
but i wanted to know if i could just
shout out the uh
number for the intim if anybody's
intimidated at the polls with what's
coming up in the next two days
um yes and before you do that alicia i
know that
are you gonna do you have a national
number because i'm aware of a list going
around of state numbers we're in each
state you need to call your state but
are
is there a federal number that you're
referring to yeah the 866r vote
please yeah i just wanted to let anybody
know
that if anybody comes up and questions
you about
where you're from your status
are you know where you live anything uh
tries to intimidate you in any way
that's
not a poll worker poll workers aren't
even allowed to ask you those questions
right nobody
the only poll worker you'd be talking to
is you get to the table and you explain
who you are and give your address
yeah and they check if you're eligible
and um i've put it on twitter
uh but i and it's gotten a lot of
retweets but
i just wanted to come on and see if i
got picked to let everybody know that if
you ever feel intimidated about voting
it's the 186 hour vote our
vote 866 hour vote is that the number
yes correct perfect all right alicia
thank you let's hope for good numbers on
tuesday
thank you so much david have a good day
all right there it is there is alicia
donald trump is continuing to speak that
is going to do it for me this is the
same as
every rally and there's another one
later today in florida and i think
there's actually two more rallies
scheduled today
it's sort of all the same i'm done with
rallies for today
so you can continue the coverage on
other channels if you want but i will be
back with you
guys tomorrow tomorrow thank you for
joining me
you